und wir wollen dieser sendung die voll
war mit drastischen dramatischen bildern
zunächst aus wolfsburg dann zuletzt aus
new york dann doch ein gewisses happy
end geben wir wollen nämlich sprechen
mit bibi und tina zwei stars die sich im
moment auch sozusagen in quarantäne
befinden nämlich nicht zur schule gehen
können und uns einmal gesagt haben wie
im moment denn ihr alltag in dieser
corona krise so aussieht
wir sind zu hause einen charakter aus
dem sperrig glaubt seitdem denken mehr
ich bin genauso wie ina ich glaube jetzt
zweieinhalb wochen leicht seit dem 1560
mehr
ich vermisse es am meisten mich mit
meinen freunden zu treffen und eben den
sport den ich sonst nach natürlich die
freude die man jeden tag gesehen hat
aber auch der alltag einfach wieder in
die schule zu gehen wieder nach hause zu
kommen
sport zu machen diesen ganzen alltag in
vermisst man schon aber dadurch wird es
stand also abwechseln ist auch ganz gut
in mathe oder so ist es eben
anspruchsvoll sicht ist alles selbst zu
erklären und selbst beizubringen aber
den meisten fächern ist es eigentlich
eine ordnung
man hat halt auch zeit um zum beispiel
zu lesen oder kreative sachen zu machen
zumal solche sachen hat man halt zeit
die man sonst nicht machen konnte
ich hätte von mir viel über kurze video
anrufe und ihr war so eine app die
heizhaus party ich glaube halt auch wenn
leute auf der strasse masken tragen ist
es für kleine kinder schon ein bisschen
angst einflößend also man ist dann schon
mal so ein bisschen erschreckt aber es
ist natürlich sinnvoll dass sich das auf
keinen fall weiter ausweitet oder so
schnell ich denke es wird also wenn sich
weiter ausbreitet und ich besser wird
halte ich es für durchaus sinnvoll weil
ich denke es ist wirklich wichtig ist
dass man den virus bald unter kontrolle
bekommen bibi und tina zur corona krise
hierbei bild